kolleginnen und kollegen diese
regierungserklärung war dringlich
denn selten zuvor war die politik der
regierung zur erklärungsbedürftig
wesentliche inhalte kannten wir aber
bereits nicht erst sagt der
pressekonferenz vom gestrigen abend bei
der unterrichtung der
fraktionsvorsitzenden denn vorgestern
bereits haben medien berichtet über das
was das bundeskanzleramt mit den
landesregierungen besprechen will
während gestern das parlament hier
getagt hat und sich mit anderen dingen
beschäftigt hat war für die breite
öffentlichkeit die
entscheidungsgrundlage der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz bereits im
internet zum download verfügbar
ich rate ab frau merkel diesen umgang
mit dem parlament zur ständigen
staatspraxis werden zu lassen
aus gutem grund haben drei fraktionen
dieses hauses deshalb dazu geraten und
dringend darum gebeten dass sie vor der
runde mit den ländern den deutschen
bundestag über ihre absichten und
grundlinien unterrichten
damit haben wir nichts unmögliches
verlangt denn im vorfeld des
europäischen rates entspricht das der
praxis der regierung und entspricht dem
umgang der regierung mit diesem
parlament
das hätte die möglichkeit geboten das
sie ihre maßnahmenvorschläge darstellen
es hätte die chance eröffnet auch die
wissenschaftlichen grundlagen zu
hinterfragen und es wäre vor allen
dingen darum gegangen alternative
strategien hier in die debatte
einzubringen
sie haben
die möglichkeit leider ausgeschlagen
dabei wäre es eine chance auch für ihre
regierung gewesen um verständnis und
vertrauen der menschen zu werden liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben's
unverändert mit einer gefährlichen
pandemie zu tun
wer die gefahren die mit der kogit
erkrankung verbunden sind relativiert
der handelt fahrlässig oder gar
vorsätzlich aber wir leben nun auch ein
jahr in und mit dieser pandemie
wir haben wie die frau bundeskanzlerin
gesagt hat gelernt die infektionszahlen
gehen zurück
es gibt zu langsame und zu beschwerlich
aber immerhin fortschritte bei den
impfungen und deshalb und angesichts der
grossen erschöpfung in unserer
gesellschaft waren die erwartungen an
die gestrige runde groß diese hoffnungen
sind enttäuscht worden denn viele
menschen haben sich mehr erwartet als an
frischen haarschnitt
ihr wesentlicher ansatz ihrer strategie
findet sich auch in dieser vorlage ich
zitiere der grundsatz wir bleiben zu
hause bleibt das wesentliche instrument
im kampf gegen die pandemie zitat ende
wirklich auch nach einem jahr noch trotz
allem was wir gelernt haben hangeln wir
uns seit oktober november von einem lock
down von einem gipfel zum nächsten ohne
eine klare perspektive
das ist bestenfalls einfallslos mit
sicherheit für merkel ist das nicht
alternativlos
christiane woopen die vorsitzender des
europäischen ethikrates in diesem haus
von vielen sehr geschätzt und mit
sicherheit eine verantwortungsbewusste
und umsichtige persönlichkeit hat dieser
tage in einem interview folgendes gesagt
ich zitiere seit einem jahr drehen sich
diese runden fast unverändert um das
gleiche den lock down
ich halte es für dringend erforderlich
eine perspektive zu eröffnen statt
durchhalteparolen zu verkünden und
weiter verboten
ich habe kein verständnis mehr dafür
dass man vorhandene technologien nichts
nutzt
wir haben dafür auch kein verständnis
mehr verraten warum orientieren wir uns
nicht an kommunen wie tübingen oder
rostock wo sind die wirksam und hier im
hause oft genug angemahnten strategien
zum wirklichen schutz der wohlhabenden
gruppen und zwar nicht nur in alten- und
pflegeheim sondern auch etwa durch die
oft hier angemahnten exklusiven
zeitfenster für den einkauf oder taxi
gutscheine
wo ist die breite initiative luftfilter
in die praxis zu bringen wo setzen wir
systematisch schnelltests ein
und warum wurde die korona war mit
großen erwartungen öffentlich
vorgestellt
und dann nach technologisch kein
bisschen weiterentwickelt
deshalb lagen hinter unseren
möglichkeiten zurück und deshalb
orientieren wir uns ausschließlich auf
den stillstand statt auch mit der
bedrohung durch das virus neue
möglichkeiten für gesellschaftliches
leben zu eröffnen und die werden wir
brauchen denn wir können uns nicht
sicher sein dass dies die einzige
torlose ist mit der die menschheit in
den nächsten jahren umzugehen hat wir
können uns noch nicht mal sicher sein ob
es nicht der einzelne mutation geben
könnte dieser erkrankung auf die die
impfung eben nicht mehr die wirksame
antwort ist mindestens nicht mit den
vorhandenen impfstoffen
also brauchen wir jetzt methoden und
eine infrastruktur mit der wir die
pandemie besser ausbalancieren mit dem
gesundheitsschutz der notwendig ist aber
der freiheit die die menschen auch leben
müssen
über monate haben wir uns an der zahl 50
nach den instanzen orientiert obwohl sie
eine politische setzung ist obwohl
oberbürgermeister auch
cdu-oberbürgermeister sagen
selbstverständlich können sie auch mehr
als 50 infektionen pro 100000 einwohner
in der woche inzwischen nach erfolgen
wir haben uns auf diese zahl von 50 in
deutschland fixiert und nun wird sie
ersetzt durch die 35 in der zentralen
bedeutung und wir wissen dass im
kanzleramt auch schon über die 10 als
zahl gesprochen worden ist
dadurch dass die wesentliche
entscheidungsgrundlage ausgetauscht wird
ohne vorbereitung ohne klare
argumentation gefährden sie die
akzeptanz der maßnahmen in der
bevölkerung insgesamt
wo ist die berechenbarkeit
im infektionsschutzgesetz übrigens wird
ausdrücklich auch ein regionaler zugang
angemahnt im von der großen koalition
beschlossenen infektionsschutzgesetz
wird angemahnt regional zu
differenzieren
tatsächlich haben wir heute bereits eine
vielzahl von landkreisen unter 50
darunter 35 und trotzdem gelten dort die
gleichen beschränkungen wie in den hot
hot spots mit über 200 incidents da ist
bereits der zweifel an der
verhältnismäßigkeit angelegt frau
bundeskanzlerin
es ist richtig kitas und schulen zu
öffnen aber auch in ihrer
regierungserklärung hier haben sie
gerade deutlich gemacht mit recht
hinhaltenden widerstand aus dem
kanzleramt dies erfolgt herr kretschmann
hat das in der runde dem vernehmen nach
gestern auch angesprochen warum stellt
frau carlitscheck finanziert mit
öffentlichen fördergeldern in dieser
woche eine wissenschaftliche studie vor
unter welchen bedingungen mit welchem
paket an maßnahmen in der pandemie die
förderung von kindern und jugendlichen
in kitas und schulen möglich ist wenn
die eigenen empfehlungen des
bundesbildungsministeriums im
bundeskanzleramt nicht ernst genommen
werden sie öffnen die friseure
sie öffnen die friseure obwohl das eine
so genannte körpernahe dienstleistung
ist man sich wirklich nun sehr nahe
kommt beim haarschnitt das ermöglichen
sie war sie weil sie sagen gut da gibt
es hier keine konzepte
da wird die maske getragen und deshalb
ist es verantwortbar den friseur zu
öffnen das ist richtig aber gibt es
solche hygiene konzepte nur bei den
friseuren nicht in gleicher weise im
sport in fitnessstudios die auch
gesundheits präventive wirkung haben
gibt es diese gesundheitskonzept wenn
ich auch im bereich der kosmetik sind
sie ausgeschlossen beim handel gar in
der gastronomie sind solche hygiene
konzepte denkbar
deshalb
die entscheidung für die friseure
bereits den makel einer nicht
systematischen ausnahme was wir brauchen
ist eine systematik klarer wenn dann
regeln weil nur dass die berechenbarkeit
für die menschen und übrigens auch für
die behörden bringt diese systematik im
wege eines stufenplans war von ihnen vor
drei wochen ja bereits auch angekündigt
worden
diese arbeitsgruppe falls sie getagt
hatte kein ergebnis
wir haben deshalb in dieser woche einen
7 stufenplan vorgelegt mit welcher
systematik es möglich ist regional zu
öffnen
und dieser von uns vorgelegten
stufenplan ist natürlich getragen von
unseren grundüberzeugungen vielleicht
stärker als andere fraktionen hier im
haus setzen wir vertrauen in die
eigenverantwortung der menschen und
setzen wir darauf dass es für große
probleme auch innovative technische
lösungen gibt das muss nicht jeder
teilen
aber es gibt eben auch andere stufen
plänen innerhalb der landesregierung von
rheinland pfalz mit sozialdemokratie und
den grünen wird darüber nachgedacht die
landesregierung von schleswig-holstein
mit union und grünen und fdp war die
erste die einen solchen stufenplan
vorgelegt hat wem also unser stufenplan
der hier liberalen charakter hat zu weit
gehend ist der findet mit unterstützung
der eigenen kolleginnen und kollegen in
den ländern auch politische alternativen
dass wir als bundesregierung der noch
untätig geworden sind und den einmal
nicht erfüllten arbeitsauftrag einfach
in die zukunft fortschreiben das zeigt
dass sie in wahrheit gar kein interesse
an einem solchen perspektiv plan haben
so notwendig er auch ist deshalb
verehrte anwesende meine damen und
herren
ist diese regierungserklärung eine
enttäuschung sie ist bedauerlicherweise
nur ein weiter so
und mein letzter gedanke wenn sie schon
den locker und jetzt weiter verschärfen
wer weiß wie lange dann passen sie ihre
wirtschaftlichen hilfen auch an ein
schweres versäumnis dass die
sozialdemokratie und herr scholz immer
noch nicht ihren widerstand aufgegeben
haben gegen das unbürokratische
schnellste und wirksamste instrument
betriebe und selbstständige zu
unterstützen nämlich den vollen
steuerlichen verlust rück tag und zwar
auf die ganzen letzten jahre seit 2000
[Applaus]